right thanks um
and thank you all for coming it's great
to see so many of you here uh i made it
over here from utrecht in the
netherlands yesterday i think i heard
some dutch where the duchies
everybody say
yeah yeah all right thanks if you don't
know what that means ask a duchy
but
yeah welcome everyone um
to this 90-minute tutorial uh which is
very is an introductory level tutorial
to using desk
um i'll start with a little bit about me
ben already said my name is richard i'm
a developer advocate at coiled coiled is
the company built around desk by the
founder of dasc
matt rocklin
i have a background to be honest kind of
all over the place i'm a curious guy i
kind of like to hop around
what i do but i
yeah i have a background in design
communication sciences research and at
the moment i'm interested in parallel
and cloud computing
i toy around with some arabic nlp in my
free time
and i
love to ferment things
i've got a big jar of miso somewhere
hidden in my attic that needs to sit
there for another year
i'll let you know how that tastes next
year um
feel free to connect with me on medium
linkedin
or just walk up to me
after the after the talk
so in the next 90 minutes
uh we'll first spend about 10 minutes
kind of building some intuition
around what is desk and why might you be
interested
in it
we'll then spend a good chunk of time
working through some das code
and we'll have some time for q a and
discussion at the end
experience says that this never
quite works this neatly and usually they
kind of merge so feel free to ask
questions in the middle of the tutorial
i think ben has a microphone um that we
can pass around
let's make this interactive
your questions will help me be more
useful to you
so we'll talk about what is desk
how can i use it
and then what about
any other questions you might have
so to start off with
why
are you here
um
and i'll ask a question first how many
people here use pandas on a regular
basis
okay almost the entire room what about
numpy
psychic learn
all right this is a pretty steady steady
percentage um and how many of you run
into
memory issues with any of those three
libraries
okay smaller smaller amount of people
how many of you
have tried to or use spark or pi spark
okay
cool sounds like a lot of you are in the
right room
chances are you're here because either
your code is running slow
uh your data doesn't fit in memory
anymore
or both which
is the worst of both worlds but that can
help
basically this is a diagram to
explain when you might want to consider
using dask on the x-axis we have data
size y-axis we have computation time
if you're in the lower left quadrant
your data fits in memory it's running
fast enough
don't bother with desk
stay away use pandas use numpy use
psychic learn
but if you are
running into any of the other issues we
just mentioned so either your code is
running too slow you're running into
memory errors or both
dusk is worth giving a try
and to illustrate
a little bit of what
a little sort of metaphor of how dusk
works this is a i'm going to actually
try and speed this up even further
um
this is a video of a
amish community raising a barn
literally in a day about 10 hours to be
in fact
and um i like to always show this
to um
illustrate what you can do when a lot of
workers agents things work together in
parallel right so this is um
pretty impressive
[Laughter]
and um
we'll tie this back to how desk works uh
later on in the tutorial but kind of
keep keep this um in mind as to
illustrate kind of the power of what you
can do with a lot of things working on
the same thing in parallel
let's see
so task unlocks the power of parallel
computing for pi data users
which means that you can process more
data
in less time
very simple we'll get kind of more into
the weeds as we as we go
um how does das do that
i found this
a picture of a do-it-yourself uh
distributed computing cluster that
someone put together which i thought was
just too epic not to share um this is a
very do-it-yourself uh low-tech way to
create
a cluster which can
process more data
uh than any one of these units alone
could ever do by itself right so the
idea
um and yeah you can get kind of into the
difference between parallel and
distributed computing but basically to
keep it simple for now
one core
can always do less than more cores so if
we can string multiple cores together
we can process more data hopefully also
faster
if you're unfamiliar with distributed
computing parallel computing i've
written a beginner's guide to
distributed computing which i can
recommend which kind of walks through
some basic concepts
the link is in the slides and the slides
will be shared afterwards
so
just to kind of reiterate why do we want
to scale python
i'm going to start with pandas i think
most of the hands that were raised were
pandas users
this is kind of very basic pandas code
to load a
one month of new york city taxi data a
single csv file
which i think is about
two gigabytes
into memory with pd.read csv
basic
nothing new here
now if we try to load in all of the data
which is 12 csv files 12 months gets to
about 15 gigabytes
that error errors out on my machine
because it can't fit into my machine's
memory
and here we run into the fact that
pandas
is limited to working on a single core
dasc exists to solve this problem and
also many others as we'll see
and ask
kind of we'll see later you can kind of
think about it as a parallel computing
engine
that plugs into pi data libraries like
pandas numpy scikit-learn and xgboost
so if this is the pandas race car which
we all know we like we like to drive it
we know how to uh steering wheel works
where the where the where the
the gear stick is um it's a great car
but it has these limits on the amount of
data that you can process
with it
so i just said desk is kind of you can
think about it as kind of a parallel
engine
that can plug into the pandas race car
panel's data frame so it's going to look
and feel like the same car but it's got
a different engine which means similar
api same look and feel
but all of a sudden you don't have these
limits on data size anymore
so here we create a
665 million row data set with task write
it to parquet
if we try to load this in to pandas
either get a memory error or your
jupyter kernel dies or
something
of that sort
but if we read it in with task
all of a sudden
we can
not only read in the data set but
perform computations over that entire
data set
and as you'll see
slight tweak instead of pd we use dd dot
read parquet
and we add
a compute call at the end of most
das
computations
because task
is able to process things in parallel by
using lazy evaluation
which we'll talk about in more detail
soon
so
again this is pretty high level but
you can think of pandas plus a das
engine giving you a das data frame
um as i said pandas
processes your data frame or loads it
into memory into a single core
das distributes this over all of the
cores in your machine it could be four
if you have four eight if you have eight
and it does that uh literally by
chopping your data up into small into
pandas data frames that can be processed
on each core
and then there's some logic that will
bring all the results back
into
into the das data frame
so this is faster
most of the time unless you're working
with data that already fits in memory on
your single core then you should just
use pandas
and it's scalable
you can scale this up
to multiple machines in a
cloud cluster for example
so the same das code that you write on
your laptop locally to scale out to your
multiple cores
can scale out to a cloud cluster you
don't have to change your code at all
and das does this for pandas but also
for numpy scikit-learn xgboost and it's
also the parallel engine under a lot of
other
python libraries like prefect and x-ray
so numpy with the das engine gives you a
desk array scikit-learn with a dash
engine gives you das ml
extra boost
you get the point
not only that so these are kind of the
high level libraries that
that desk offers
but underneath that you can go lower
level um and ask offers a lower level
api that lets you scale any arbitrary
python function
for parallel processes process
processing sorry
um so there you can take a python code a
for loop that
runs sequentially
and wrap it in
das delayed again we'll see this in more
detail later
but then all of a sudden your same
python code is distributed over all the
cores on your laptop or the cores in
your cluster
and this gives task a lot of flexibility
too so something like spark is generally
more limited to kind of map reduce
paradigm
delayed gives you a lot more flexibility
about how you build your own task graphs
uh and um using dependencies from
different tasks and things like that
this is kind of getting in the weeds but
um i always like to point this out
now what is coiled in this whole das
world uh coiled is a way to run das in
the cloud
so you can run dusk in the cloud
by yourself you can set up your own desk
gateway or kubernetes and do all of your
own security deployments and everything
but it will probably take you a couple
of days
you'll have to put someone on
maintaining that
coiled offers a paid way
to do that
for you so we can run class das clusters
in the cloud
spin them up in a couple of minutes
with two lines of code and then you can
run
code from your laptop in the cloud in
your aws or gcp account
so we take away the devops part of
deploying das
in the cloud
and again we'll see this in more detail
later
so just to wrap up this kind of
intuition part that we're starting this
tutorial with um das is an engine for
high performance parallel computing
you can step right into sort of
pre-built das race cars right these are
the high level apis
das data frame desk array das ml
that parallelize
code or data frame or array or or
scikit-learn code for you so you don't
have to worry about how it gets
parallelized you can just sort of step
right into it
or you can go a step deeper and
build your own parallel
task graphs
with the lower level api task delayed
before we jump into the next part of the
tutorial where we're going to get
to write some das code any questions at
this point
is different right it's not
that there is
the same
so
there's not one answer to that so for
some some things uh so xg boost offers a
native das integration so you just say
you import the dask dot
xg boost regressor
and that will automatically link up to
wherever you're running desk
that's ml is a re-implementation mostly
wrappers around scikit-learn
any other questions
for now
no great
then let's
write some code i was very proud of this
animation sorry can you all clap for me
that would be great yeah thanks
[Applause]
so there was a link in the uh start
starting slide to a repo this will take
you there as well
there's two ways to run the code during
this session
you can either clone the repository
there's
a binder directory with an
environment.yaml file that you can use
to create your local conda environment
alternatively you can click on the
launch binder button and that will spin
up a binder
notebook for you where you can run the
code
so let's
get into that
actually let me
yeah so this is the repository um
are folks
comfortable with the binder
uh notebook or launching is actually let
me rephrase that question is everyone
anyone having trouble
finding this repository or getting
started with
binder or finding the notebooks
great
in that case
we will start with the first notebook
which is the test drive
um
usually i run through this notebook and
kind of show how it works i'm going to
try something different today and give
you all a couple of minutes
that you can run this notebook yourself
top to bottom so i'm just going to give
folks a couple of minutes to run the
cells and kind of get a feel for it
let's say two minutes
and
after that i'll run through it myself
and if people have questions
right now feel free to ask them as they
come up
okay
you
you
do you have the microphone sorry yeah
thanks
so even when when i'm on a single
machine i
nonetheless go and start like a
distributed cluster well maybe so i can
see the fancy plots and the progress
bars and everything
but
it works even if you don't do that so
i'm wondering like what's the difference
between in a single machine
between starting the cluster or not yeah
so yeah the question is about is
actually a question about
the das scheduler
so their desk has a few different
schedulers that will
do things like create the task graphs
i'm going to leave this question for
right after this notebook because then
we'll have a nice diagram that shows the
the architecture of a das cluster but
it's a great question and i'll come back
to it
all right
any other questions after
folks ran through this test drive
notebook right now
right the question is how much of pandas
is covered in the das data frame api can
you just drop in replacement everything
um no you cannot drop and replace
everything because you're moving from
sequential programming to distributed
computing um it's really kind of a
different universe you have to think
about
state data transfer
data duplicates things like that
and some things like calculating a
median in a distributed setting is
actually very difficult
so that's something that
is there are some workarounds in some
cases but you'll find that it's not as
easily implemented in the dash data
frame api
so yeah how much i can't give you an
exact percentage if i would kind of like
give a rough estimate i would say 85
and the biggest difference as we'll see
in a little bit is that you often you
always have to add the compute
call at the end yeah
all right so
i'll run through this very quickly since
you uh all just run through this
yourselves but basically um we'll start
by test driving
let me there we go
yeah
no there's a piano sound i hear it too
yeah
excellent thanks
thanks
right so we'll um
import das dataframe sdd
there we go
run a
quick script to download some data
and as we saw before we can use the read
csv method
with dd instead of pd to read the files
we can call head
on our dask data frame
and we can compute
group by
just adding the compute at the end here
because if we don't do that
we see that dusk is extremely fast
16.2 microseconds
and that is because das hasn't actually
done anything so when you
instruct task to do something like this
all it does is
create a task graph which is sort of
like a recipe a route to say okay i know
where all the data is i know how to get
to this result i will not get it until
you specifically tell me to
because there might be a situation where
this result is too big to store
in your local client
so you this is the difference between
pandas whenever you instruct it to do
something it immediately does it it's
called eager evaluation
das uses lazy evaluation where it won't
actually compute anything until you
specifically tell it to
and now it will run the computation and
get you the result
so that also means that if you just call
the data frame in pandas here you would
see
contents of
that data frame with task all you get is
sort of some some structure so schema
information about the column names the
data types and the number of partitions
and partitions you can get it from the
word right das cuts your data up into
smaller parts partitions and each of
these partitions when working with das
data frame is a pandas data frame so
each and that's why
das can cover so much of the pandas api
is that it's executing pandas operations
on pandas objects uh behind the sce the
scene and then synthesizing those back
very
kind of lightning test drive
we'll dig into more detail later
task array we'll import it
as d a
this will be this similar look and feel
as
numpy except again lazy evaluation so
you call the array you don't get the
data but you get some information about
it
in array
the parts are not called partitions but
chunks don't ask me why it's one of the
things that frustrates me the most
about task
but you know things evolve and uh people
get attached um
so yeah here you see it has 100 the
array is made up of 100 chunks each
chunk is 7.63 megabytes um
and then again we can call kind of numpy
methods or do numpy operations but we
have to specify the compute to actually
get that result
done
das ml
this will be very similar to the
scikit-learn
api
and not sure why this is taking so long
did anyone else have trouble running
this
you did
okay
okay there we go
um so yeah these again are will be dask
arrays that are made as part of a kind
of synthetic data generation method we
instantiate a das
ml version of the logistic regression
regression model
we fit it
on the data and we can make our
predictions
and i would say to answer your question
again about how much
of the api uh
uh desk covers uh with scikit-learn i
would say it's the lowest percentage uh
because not every algorithm can be run
in parallel so basically das ml runs
can work with algo rhythms that have the
end jobs parameter
that that are able to be run run in
parallel
a quick test drive of the lower level
api that i discussed so this is das
delayed this is the api that lets you
create your own parallel python code
so here we are defining two functions
one that increments x by one
and one that adds a bunch of variables
together each one of these function
will take
a second because we are sleeping for one
second
if we run this in normal python
guess how long this will take
three seconds
and we'll have the result right because
each function takes a second so one two
and then adding them together is another
second
now if we were to run this in parallel
because the two increment
calls
are independent right you can increment
x by one and y by one separate from each
other
so you could run those in parallel if
python was able to do that
it doesn't do that by default but by
wrapping it in a delayed
wrapping it with a dash delayed
object
again super fast how did we do it
only the task graph has been built again
so we have we get a delayed object not
the actual result in this case
and on delayed objects we can call
visualize
which starts to give us an idea of how
the task graph is being built
so a
is the increment function
with input 1
wrapped in in das delayed
so we're calling the function inc
and we'll get a result
squares are results and um circles are
tasks
b
is the identical task graph it's the the
function inc being called once
and c
will look like this
so they're read from bottom to top
two ink calls that can be run in
parallel that feed into an add call that
will give us our final result
so
quick
check
how long will this take to run
i hear two and i hear three who says two
who says three
two seconds the two ink calls run
together
this of course depends on how many cores
you have in your laptop if i only had
one core
this would still run in three seconds
luckily we're beyond that state of
technology but if we now add
another variable d
then we get three calls to inc
and this will run again in two seconds
because i have eight cores in this
machine so i could go up to eight calls
of ink and this would still run in two
seconds
beyond that it will
take more more time
so this is a very simple task graph this
is nice we all get it
things can get a lot more complicated
people tend to have two different
reactions to these task graphs they find
them either intimidating or exciting
no judgment on what your reaction is if
you find them intimidating the good news
is das data frame desk array dascaml you
never have to worry about building your
task graph das does that under the hood
it's optimized
good luck trying to do it better
if you are working with use cases or
projects that don't fit into a data
frame or an array model or sometimes do
and sometimes don't
or you think you can beat dusk
you can use das delayed to build your
own task graphs
and finally
we talked about running desk in the
cloud with coiled
we'll illustrate this
at a few times in
in this tutorial if you want to run
the code below
you can create an account
at coiled
cloud.coil.io you just need to put in
your github or your
google credentials
you'll instantly have an account so no
sort of credit card identification
anything like that
and then
you can
[Music]
run the following commands open a
tournament terminal create a new
environment
uh
install this meta package which will get
you dask and coiled and everything you
need sorry this one
and then run coiled login
the coiled login will
prompt you to put in a token um
i've made this token available for this
tutorial um so that normally you'd have
to set up your own aws or gcp account
but just so that we could all if people
are interested here right now they can
try it right now you'll all spin up in
my account so i'll pay for all of your
cloud costs
but after today you'll have to pay for
it yourself
so
we can import coiled
and run this cell
actually did i run this i don't think i
did okay
to spin up a coiled cluster
so here we are spinning up
this account is set to work with aws so
in in
my aws account we are currently spinning
up a cluster with 20 workers that have
16 gigs of ram each
a docker image will be loaded onto each
worker
we've built that docker image up here
it's called the coiled software
environment
and this is launching now
so we can see
provisioning the resources the instances
are booting and then it'll launch the
software environments this will take
about two or three minutes
and once this is done
you can run you can connect das to this
cluster
and any das code that you run in this
notebook
will not be run on your laptop but will
be run on the cloud
so if you want to give this a spin
while we wait
for the cluster to launch
i'll leave the instructions up here
we'll have
again two minutes
for folks to try that out
and if uh there are any questions i'm
happy to take those now
if i understand that correctly in like
this distributed cluster you just showed
the runtime environment that the worker
will use is defined by the docker image
that you provide yeah
which means that if you wanted an
additional dependency you would have to
update
the image accordingly
yeah thank you for pointing out my
biggest frustration with our platform at
the moment
[Laughter]
uh yeah you're right and we're working
on
a way to not have to do that anymore so
to be fair this is already a big step
forward right having to build your own
docker image and distribute that on a
cloud cluster is a lot of work the fact
that you can do that with two cells of
code is a step forward
but it's not yet as flexible as we want
it to be uh so our yeah our uh we're
start-up our product is iterating every
week um
we just have put in a a pr
um that works with poetry uh instead of
uh to try and see if we can
build something where you can just add
dependencies
why your cluster is live
thank you maybe as a quick follow-up
what would be your recommended strategy
right now for a multi-user setup where
every user possibly has their own
environment because
the best thing we could come up with is
having each user like spin up a large
compute resource and having tasks run
locally on that resource
which is not distributed in the
classical sense of the word but it gets
the job done so do you have a an idea
how we could like make it better
um
sorry can you uh say the first part of
your question again
rather than having like each user spin
up their own das cluster on their local
machine to avoid this problem of you
know possibly different environments in
the workers
is is there is there an alternative to
that
yeah and the problem is that different
users need different dependencies yes
yeah
so in our case we would say each user
builds a coiled software environment
that works for them and spins up their
own cluster
i guess alternatively you could build an
environment that works for everybody but
that seems less flexible and less
optimal to me yeah cool thank you
any other questions
in the back ben thanks
do you support uh azure
as a cloud provider not at the moment
okay no we're working on it um we can
talk about it afterwards but um not at
the moment thanks another question you
haven't sort of explored the data very
much what do you recommend for
visualization
for large data amounts sorry yeah which
frameworks do you recommend for
visualizing large amounts of data with
task
data shader so data shader is built with
uh dusk under the hood um do you know
data shader yeah yeah yeah i was just
wondering if there was anything else but
i guess
that's probably what
that's what i use yeah that's what i
would recommend
okay so in the meantime this has
completed um
we can go to the coiled dashboard in
this case
i see that some people are
spinning up clusters that's great um
and then
i didn't follow my own advice and didn't
put my name in so yeah we've got a bunch
of insert your name here
but
this is our cluster that's running
and this is maybe partly also to answer
your question um you can have team
accounts in coiled and see kind of an
admin can see whose clusters are
spinning up you can set user limits to
those clusters um and here you can see
the software environments that are
running
um
yeah
so now that we have that set up
um
right now if we still if we run our das
code nothing will happen on our cluster
because by default task will run your
code locally so we have to tell das
instead of running things locally please
connect to this cluster that's running
and to do that we create a client
and this is gets to your question one in
this case we create a distributed
task scheduler
which will start to communicate to the
cluster
and
if we now read in this data
i think this is my cluster i hope so
this will start to read in
the full data set that we couldn't read
in locally on my machine before so this
is all 12
csv files being read in at once
i feel like maybe the internet
connection is a bit slower than
i was hoping
well i'm going to run this and then
we'll see
what we can do
dask offers a dashboard nothing's
happening at the moment so you don't see
anything
this is um
yeah again
this would
run faster normally
but this is where you can
unlike pandas task offers you a lot of
visibility in the code that's running so
you don't have to look at a jupiter cell
with an asterisk next to it but you can
see the tasks that are running on which
workers the amount of memory that they
take up and things like that so i hope i
will be able to demonstrate that
later
but for the sake of time let's move on
there we go
okay
i will do it this way
okay
love it when things don't do what you
expect them to do
let's move on to the next notebook and
then we'll come back to this
um
this is more to answer your question uh
juan
a notebook with no code just to kind of
talk about uh the desk architecture and
some basic concepts
so we saw already you can use dask to
parallelize pandas with similar api
and we also talked about the different
collections so desk array das data frame
das bag is one that i didn't mention yet
but it's a high-level api for working
with unstructured
data things like json
and then
you have the lower level api which are
das delayed in futures all of these apis
create task graphs
and these task graphs are run by
schedulers
there are technically four schedulers
you can forget all of them for today
except for the distributed one
the first three all run only on a single
machine and then they run either threads
the processes are synchronous
the threaded single machine runner is
what you will get by default so by
default
das will run things backed by a thread
pool
you can run things with processes
instead
but the distributed scheduler
is what we recommend uh
also when working locally the
distributed scheduler gives you access
to the dashboard
which is still not showing anything um
and um yeah it's optimized and once you
use the distributed
scheduler so that's what we instantiated
here with the client
you can run that locally and then plug
in the cluster and then your same code
will
run in the cloud
so we have a client uh the client is
wherever your python code is running
that could be an ipython session a
jupyter notebook
it could be a prefect task
uh an airflow task a github action
anything that can run python code can
create a das scheduler and a desk
cluster
a das cluster is made up of the
scheduler that orchestrates
all of partitioning the data and then
distributing it and bringing it back and
the actual computation is done by
workers um if you're working locally
usually workers will be the number of
cores that you have in your machine
once you scale out to the cloud
yeah it's potentially limitless
to kind of go back to our
amish barn raising
analogy that we saw at the beginning
you're trying to build this big data
project
and the people who are doing the work
are your cores your task workers they're
using python libraries as their tools so
you have access to to all the python
libraries that you need
and they do that following
a blueprint that's the task the task
graph that we saw and you can build that
task graph yourself with the low level
apis or das can do it for you with
things like data frame and desk array
and then the das scheduler sort of the
general contractor who's keeping an eye
out
on that things are going as efficiently
as possible
um
yeah we saw this at the beginning but
again
we find it really important to iterate
that
you really should not use das if you
don't need it right so using desk means
you're entering distributed computing um
one it's more it's complicated there's a
lot of new concepts you need to learn
two a lot of things can go wrong it's
very hard to debug when you're running
and distributed
so don't go there if you don't need to
if pandas and numpy are doing the job
for you stay there um but if you need if
they're not giving you what you need
then task is there and um has been
designed to make the transition from
pandas to dusk or numpy to desk as
smooth as possible
there's some more material here
that folks can check out
at your own leisure afterwards
[Music]
i'm
very interested what happened here
because yeah okay so this ran but we
missed it
fair enough
let's see if we can check that i got
again later um
let's go to notebook 2 dash data frames
to dive in a little deeper into the das
data frame api
i'm just going to check what i'm doing
on time
we're halfway i think is that correct
yeah
okay
yeah so
some of this we've seen before
so i'll just run these cells
to read in the same data that we loaded
in before you'll see that
um to load in a das data frame you get
this schema with some basic information
about
the data set but not the data itself
this includes things like the columns
and the d types
for these things you don't need to add
compute
because they are already brought in
memory it's just kind of the schematic
information
the number of partitions in this case
10.
i'm actually curious what happens if we
do
ddf.visualize right
so
this data frame is the result of 10
parallel calls to read csv
each
call is read into one partition
which will be
a pandas data frame
we could
re-partition this data frame to say okay
actually i want partitions that are 100
megabytes each
and
interestingly enough let's see
right
so each one of these is a read csv call
and then a partition repartition call
so i mentioned this uh already in
passing but just to kind of visualize it
already
the four part parts in this case make up
the das data frame and each single
partition is actually a pandas data
frame which is why we can use
pandas operations on them
did the visualize already
you can call ahead on a das data frame
without the compute because it calls it
uses compute under the hood
very similar as pandas
now let's look at something a little bit
more involved
so
if we wanted to compute the largest
flight departure delay in our data set
we could do this in pandas by iterating
over each csv file separately and then
joining them together
and then we could also wrap that pandas
code in a dask delayed to have that run
in parallel
but that's actually what that data frame
does for you
so we just call max on the departure
column departure delay column
and this again won't actually give us
our result because we haven't called
compute so this has built the task graph
in the background
it starts to look a little more like the
barn
that we're building
so yeah we have 10 calls to read csv
we're getting a column from each csv
file
we're computing the max over each
chunk and then combining aggregating the
max over all of those chunks to get the
final result
if we had 10 cores these could all run
in parallel
up until this point everything is lazy
uh we need to call the compute to
actually
trigger the computation
and
task is smart about deleting
intermediate results so
it'll clean up files that it doesn't
need anymore
to free up memory in your cluster
right
the next
section has two examples and two
exercises
um i'll give folks five minutes to work
through those
and again if there's any questions
feel free to just ask them as we go
um you just did a re-partition right
um but if you put in a different
repetition size
don't you get
less or more partitions yeah
that should be the case
um
let me see did that not happen
it was uh
also 10 partitions
so that was my access to them two things
could have happened either it was let's
see
there we go oh well but now
actually let's say
interesting
yeah no this makes sense
yeah so the the partitions were already
100 megabytes ah okay um that makes
sense thanks for spotting
um yeah so here it's splitting up uh
into 20 because i've now specified 50
megabytes okay cool thanks
i would have had the same question but
then a different question instead you
said you're planning on integrating with
poetry
with regards to building your worker
environments yeah
are you planning on building the same
integration for the conda mamba
ecosystem as well yeah so the eventually
yeah that's the plan to do it for
everything very nice thank you
some questions back there
hi i am i was wondering when you called
um
your csv in your cluster you use
s3fs i was wondering if it was
downloading it to your machine and then
uploading it again to the cluster or is
it going directly to your cluster um
so in the other notebook you mean yeah
with s3
my cluster is running in aws so they
just it does not go through my local
client
it goes straight to the cluster yeah
one more question back there
um beforehand you mentioned that the
call or the compute graphs are not
limited to a mapreduce kind of scheme or
pattern could you name an example of an
application that
doesn't lend itself to map reduce and
can be solved with dusk
sure
i know that a lot of our customers in
financial services
use
das delayed to build
things for
back testing things like that i don't do
any of that
analysis myself so i'm hesitant to say a
whole lot more sorry i can't see your
face so it's
than that
but i know that that's one common
application
thank you
uh maybe a question these compute graphs
they all start from their read csv calls
so i guess it's reading the data every
time you call a new graph is there some
way of caching an intermediate operation
if you want to start from the same point
multiple times absolutely yeah so you
could uh run ddf2
[Music]
but persist
um i'm not going to do that i mean when
you're working locally that's not
as useful because it's just it's it
would be the same as calling compute
it's storing it in local memory uh but
when working on a cluster uh this can be
uh helpful to say okay the result
uh
of this
computation store it in in cluster
memory okay and can you also piss this
to disk
uh that's uh
yeah that's compute i mean that's uh
that that would load it to disk oh you
mean
persistent disk
i guess so yes
it's not something i've ever done myself
but okay i'm sure it's possible yeah
how are folks doing on the exercises
anyone
questions
um you said that the
plan is optimized right the task plan
and is there a way to cut up the plan in
two such at the
first part and the second part to
optimize individually
optimized for
so um for the order of tasks maybe or
the order of execution of the tasks
uh such that you have some grip on how
the optimization goes sure
i would definitely think that's possible
with dust delayed so das data frame
gives you less flexibility on how the
task graph is built but that means you
also need to think about it less so
that's the trade-off with using the high
level versus the low level
thanks for sure
all right
[Music]
let's run through the examples in the
exercises
[Music]
if we want to get the total of the
non-canceled flights in our data set
we do something that should be familiar
to most people who work in pandas
and add the compute call at the end
so we negate the canceled column and sum
that
we can get the total of the non-canceled
flights by airport
this way
um yeah and then
the solutions for these should load by
themselves
if there are no questions about this
basically the point of this is
that for
a large portion of the pandas api
it'll look exactly the same except
you're adding the compute call at the
end
now a little performance tip on when to
call compute
see this a lot with people who start
with task are so used to getting results
straight away because that's what pandas
does that they
compute all the time but remember that
you're interrupting the building of a
task graph anytime you call
compute
so it's a little bit um like cooking a
recipe and
eating the ingredients while you're
cooking it's like yeah it might taste
good but you'll miss out on
the total effect and
so in this case
let's try and compute the mean and
standard deviation for the departure
delay of all the non-cancelled flights
we can define all of them
so we get the non-canceled flights the
mean delay and the standard deviation of
the delay
and we can compute each of these
separately
take about three seconds
now alternatively
we can see
that um there's some shared
data for these two um
results that we're trying to uh compute
which is the non-cancelled uh variable
so if there's a way for us to construct
a task graph to say hey actually instead
of doing those separately join them
together so a little bit the opposite of
what you're saying
you could import task and use
dask.compute again so this is a little
bit this is the lower level
api
and this will run in about half the time
yeah this is all this is not legible
anymore but basically
things are getting shared arrows what's
the point of this diagram
um
yeah i mentioned it a little bit already
uh based on juan's question also about
the distributed scheduler
so earlier in the notebook we created
this and then connected to a cluster
object which was our remote cluster if
we just say n workers equals eight this
will create a local task cluster so
there'll be a desk scheduler process and
then eight dask workers
that will then
do your das computations
this will give you a hyperlink to the
desk dashboard and let's see fingers
crossed
if we run a group by there we go
that was very fast
but basically
this is the dashboard that gives you
insight into the computations that are
running on your cluster
let's close the client for this notebook
this is the end of the data frame
section any questions before we move on
it's been a while i've been used some
something similar to that so it was
spark and it looks very similar to now
maybe one thing that was different and i
wonder if that
just because i was a beginner spark user
or not but the way he computed the mean
and the standard deviation is that
something really like specific to the
way desk built this compute graph or
would would it would it be also
something that would be as
paralyzed before i was doing it with
spark because i
from what i remember i would have have
to do some persist in some places and
maybe
do things in a way that
it
actually shares some computations but i
wonder if
i'm just wrong there yeah uh i'm not a
avid spark user myself either so i uh
will preface my answer that with that
but i do know that das offers more
flexibility
so i i i don't know how to do this exact
computation in spark so i can't fully
answer your question
but the two
main distinguishing features between
dusk and spark are that das is pure
python
um so no jvm
and and scala error messages things like
that um and desk offers more flexibility
at the lower level to build your own
task graphs
thank you and if everyone ever anyone
knows for a spark
how well does it handle joining two data
frames
yeah um
quite well depends on
a few things
joining a large data frame to a small
data frame
is
quite performant if uh i mean yeah when
you're joining in a distributed setting
you often have to shuffle the data it
gets pretty uh pretty intensive so das
handles it well
i would say
it's up to you
to figure out whether it's the right
choice or not um
usually it involves setting the index
um
and that's that's uh that's especially
heavy yeah
okay thank you
yeah but to
continue my like the the api is is
comparable to pandas so it's a dot merge
and then the
thing yeah
all right
we have half an hour left so let's um
jump into the machine learning notebook
[Music]
this is a notebook that will illustrate
three things
we will look at
using dasc
as the back-end
two scikit-learn algorithms
so with the job lib library using das to
do things like hyperparameter search uh
on a cluster um
we will look at uh using das ml to do
actual like distributed parallel uh
algorithms and we will look at
dusk's integration with boost
so start with a quick
overview
by now you all have memorized this
diagram
quick overview of scikit-learn for
people uh i think a lot of people raise
their hands
but basically we're going to
just a
quick refresher on how psychic learn
works
in this case we're making a
synthetic classification
data set storing those in x and y
variables variables excuse me
x and y are numpy arrays
we import the model that we want to
train we instantiate it
and then we fit our model on using the x
and y data
and we can then
inspect attributes of this model
and the accuracy
if we
want to
improve this model we can do something
called hyper parameter optimization with
something like grid search
cv
we define
in this case four parameters
that we want to
train our model on to see which
combination is the best
we pass the grid search cv our estimator
the grid of the parameters um and say
how many cr cross validations we want to
do
and we fit that
and so i could learn at least in this
default setting we'll do that
sequentially so we're doing eight fits
and as you see each one will follow the
next
it takes about 16 seconds and once
that's done we can get the best
parameters and the best score
not a huge improvement from what we had
before but
at least now we know we've tested some
parameters there could be a lot more
parameters to test
and if we are i mean this is working
with you know a tiny data set and using
four parameters it's really just kind of
a toy problem right and in the real
world you're likely using a lot more
data and you'll want to try a lot more
parameters
it would be great if we could train each
one in parallel because it's just the
model being fit on the parameters
there's no exchange of information
between each right so this is an
embarrassingly parallel problem
scikit-learn has a back-end for
parallelism called job lib so any s
scikit-learn estimator that exposes the
end jobs keyword can be trained in
parallel
so in this case i would specify -1 which
will use the maximum available cores
to train this in parallel again eight
fits
it won't show them sequentially because
they're happening
together
but it trains in about half the time
no task here yet this is just pure
scikit learn
now
this is great and my machine locally
could handle this and do some speed up
but
we're still working with four parameters
and a small data set
if we were to increase the amount of
data or the amount of parameters that
we're interested in or both
running this locally on eight cores
might start to become less performant
and we might get impatient and we might
want to run it faster
and this is one way to use das to speed
up your machine learning problems
is to specify das as the back end for
joblib
so wherever dask is running is where
the parallelism will happen through
joblib
so here we will
create a local client
with eight workers eight cores
we'll
define some more parameters to make this
a little bit more interesting
well then import job lib so this is the
library that
talks to this keyword behind the scenes
and then create a context manager
and set the back end to be dask
and we'll then fit this model
this is now using the desk cluster
but actually i'm cheating here
and anyone who can spot it
um
should let me know
what is the difference between what i'm
doing here
i've created a dash cluster on my
machine with eight workers
and
here
other than the number of parameters i've
changed the number of parameters but
this is minus one which is using how
many cores
sorry
everything which is eight
and here i've created a dash cluster
using eight cores
so this is exactly the same
so actually dusk is not giving you
anything here because you're running
locally so
that doesn't make much of a difference
but if we were now to
import coiled
and say
connect to the running cluster
i'm just going to pull the name
this is why i should have given it a
better name
this is connecting to the cluster that's
already running
even though we spawned it in another
python process
and instead of saying n1 and workers i
will now put in the cluster here
actually first let me close this client
now from this point on any das
computations will be run
on my coiled cluster and not locally
so when we create this now
so this run in 26.5 seconds locally
this is now going to run on my cluster
around a bit faster we've got 20 workers
each with six to 16 gigabytes of ram
it's up to you if for this use case it
was worth spinning up a cluster in the
cloud and paying for that probably not
right it's eight seconds difference um
but just to illustrate that um nothing
about the code has changed you've just
pointed task to a different cluster
to run remotely instead of locally
any questions about this before we move
on
um yeah i was just wondering how coiled
or you can
use dusk
alongside some mlops frameworks like
sagemaker because they have their own
apis for these various
estimators that you may be using
um yes i mean
i'm not sure how i mean you could run
this in a sagemaker notebook
but you're asking i think your question
is something else well so
you're
you're calling like the psychic learn
estimators here
via the desk
apis
whereas sagemaker will
call the same via their own apis can you
integrate the two together so i'm not
using any desk api here okay this is
just pure scikit-learn
all i'm doing is uh um
um moving the parallelism to a remote
cluster
and you can do that from within a
sagemaker notebook as well yeah okay if
as long as your
sagemaker notebook is authorized with
coiled yeah but yeah okay
all right um moving on to
um
das ml which is a library that
re-implements scikit-learn algorithms to
run in parallel
on a desk
working with das data frames and dash
arrays as input
so this will look
a lot like the scikit-learn api but it's
no longer
the exact circuit learn api it's
wrappers around that
so we're making
again a synthetic
data set here now a regression data set
before we saw if we called x it was a
numpy array now that's a dash array
which will not give us any contents
because it's
lazily
constructed
we'll then instantiate a linear
regression model
this is a the das ml version
again it'll look and feel very much the
same we can fit this model
this should
yeah well
that's fitting on our cluster
and if you think
this is taking a while i wish this was
faster
um
i'd say you're a little impatient
because it's 28 seconds but
if you must
it's quite easy to skill up the cluster
that you're running on um
so now this will scale up to 100.
it'll take some time for those resources
to get um
to come online so you probably won't
beat the time that you just did
but if you're working with
things that are taking a week or a day
or you know this
scaling up your cluster
can be one way to
improve the runtime
all right um
let's see if i think
i promised the
yeah right so this is normally i'd kind
of mess around with the order a little
bit normally i would run that linear
regression locally first and then show
the speed up with coiled but we were
already running uncoiled so i'll skip
that section
and
um
to talk about xgboost so actually boost
is not within the the scikit-learn api
it's its own thing um
dasgml started out building a
das ml wrapper around xgboost
that was found so popular and effective
that actually boost decided to upstream
or integrate that into their
into their library
so you can now
access
parallelized versions of xgboost that
run on das clusters
um
if you're familiar with x2 boost there's
two apis there's the one that that
follows the scikit-learn model of fit
and
train and then there's the more uh kind
of default native xgboost api uh where
normally you would do xgboost.train and
instead of that now you do dask.train
and this will
train
in parallel
on your
task cluster
any questions
so what about if you have a
a custom operation which you want to do
on your uh data frame
um like
sometimes you can apply like a lambda
function
on a column and if it gets split between
different machines
the actual operation might be in
conflict with the way that the chunks
are distributed is there a way
to specify
[Music]
like how how
like a certain interface that i can plug
into
to specify my uh sure my function yeah
um so you
want to apply
custom functions to your dash data frame
right correct so um
there's a
method called map partitions
which will map a function
over all of the partitions
and you can pass any function that can
act on a pandas object because each
partition is a pandas data frame
and it will work like a mapreduce
kind of thing or
it will it will yeah i guess so yeah it
will map
i mean let's let's do it live what do
you want to do with this database i
don't know just you know just uh um
uh yeah i'm not sure i could do that
live on the spot right now but
[Laughter]
good one
um
yeah i don't think i can do that live on
the spot right now but uh
sorry
of
i mean yeah i think both of these are
implemented in the task api so that's
why i'm thinking you could you could use
that like k-means or something
yeah
keep it coming guys keep it going
not feeling the pressure at all
um
i'm going to quit here and not embarrass
myself any further
map partitions is a great way to map
functions over
pandas data frames that are the
partitions of your das data frame yeah
thanks
sorry
how would you recommend
implementing for example tensorflow or
pytorch or similar libraries over dusk
yeah um
[Music]
let's see
tensorflow i don't have experience with
uh pytorch um we have an example uh here
um
[Music]
yeah there's uh that gets you uh into
the kind of lower level api of that's
delayed which means it's a lot more
hands-on and involved
you can scatter the data to your cluster
and then
pass those delayed objects into
pyrotorch um i would recommend taking a
look at this this blog too
but do you have to get into the lower
level api of pytorch as well or
do you know that uh i don't think so
okay no
okay thanks
all right
um
let's go to notebook four then this digs
in a little deeper to the lower level
api das delayed
going over this before we saw it we have
the increment and the add functions
that are running sequentially that we
can then
wrap in dash delayed
to build a task graph
right
things could run in parallel
it's a very simple example
but a slightly more involved example is
how to parallelize a for loop right for
loop in uh especially in this case
is sequential um
we have a list of eight numbers for i in
that list
we will increment
i
and append the results
this will take eight seconds because
there's that sleep function in each for
loop which will sleep for one second and
we'll get the total result um
i will
give you all five minutes
to
try this exercise um
i think this one especially is worth
doing because
it really gets you to think about okay
where
is the task graph being constructed um
i got this wrong the first five times i
tried it because my intuition was to
do it differently so i'm curious
if this
is makes more sense to other folks in
the room so i will give you um
five minutes
uh to do that exercise
ten more okay
we have 10 more minutes so i will make
it three minutes
check it out
yes
uh
ladies
all right
okay
three minutes are up
um
[Music]
how many of you were able to solve this
one
okay
um
so
not sure what your intuition was
but for me i i think the first time i
tried this i just i think i just put a
delayed here it's just like that that
must work right you just kind of
wrap it around and then it'll figure
everything out
um
that doesn't work
but what does work
is
wrapping the ink function with
task delayed
and
what's happening here is that for me
what the kind of the the when i
reflected on a little bit i thought okay
i think the for loop needs to get
parallelized so i want every
iteration to run in parallel so i must
sort of
maybe create a function that does the
for loop and then
delayed wrap the later on that
but what's actually happening is the for
loop is not being parallelized so we're
creating a dash delayed object eight
times
and
the results of that
are then also wrapped in dash delayed
and so
when we visualize it
we will now see
each of these instances of increment
being run
per in parallel those are aggregated
in a sum
and this
will now run
in one
second i realize that this is very in a
way a very banal like uh illustration of
what dastylate does like when are you
ever going to use this right i think
that the
um
trouble in explaining this is that uh
explaining it for real use cases gets
extremely involved so i chose for this
case as it's an introductory uh tutorial
to kind of keep it
really uh illustrate the concept and i
hope i've done that
successfully
if not please come talk to me i i mean
i'm always uh
improving and refining this talk so i'd
love to to get feedback on things that
weren't weren't clear
um
but with that uh i will end the code
part of
this talk um the slides that i will
share
that will be shared after
the talk also include a
real world use case of desk um at
capital one one of the big u.s banks
that's worth kind of taking a look at to
see how how big organizations use desk
in production
um i'm
running out of time so that's why i'm
just kind of mentioning it but not going
through it
um if you found this interesting and are
curious about more material um about
dasc
we have a great coil blog
which has a lot of tutorials and
information about
how to use das to speed up panels and
numpy
as well as kind of the lower level
things and using das with workflow
orchestration tools like airflow and
prefect
if you're very curious to get more into
the world of task graphs and how does
desk optimize things and can i do it
better can we do it differently um then
our engineers write some great blogs
about for example
doing better shuffling and
memory management so i would recommend
those
[Music]
we have an early bird
discount offer for the four day desk
training
if that's something you're interested in
check out the link or come talk to me
and we're also in the process of writing
uh
dusk the definitive guide since i think
last week or two weeks ago the early
release is up
so this is literally our google docs as
we're writing them being pushed live
it's raw
have a look at it send me feedback
we're put building this out in the open
so that we can make this uh relevant to
the people who want to use it
you can find us here
and if there are any questions i'll take
them now
otherwise you can come find me later
in the whole outside
any last questions before we end
no
then thank you very much